pedro is a data scientist based in
dublin for white light
studios
hi folks so i'm going to be talking
about light vm today we just saw an
awesome lecture here about data center
ki from maurizia and she's claimed which
i totally agree that you should focus 80
on data 20 modeling so why am i here
talking about a model i hope that
becomes clear by the end of the
presentation but before who here has
heard of light gbm
all right and what about xgboost
and have you ever actually used them in
a problem for machine learning
all right so it's a pretty technical
audience i have a rule of thumb where i
ask about tensorflow and xc boost if
people know more tensorflow this means
it's not very machine learning savvy but
this is not the case here so let's start
by dissing neural networks first
i'm not here to show you memes my
objectives are actually twofold first i
want to convince you to start using igbm
or xgboost for tableau problems if
you're not using them already and second
if you're using them i want to give a
taste of some interes interesting
features and i want to also explain how
they work roughly
i'm not going to be talking about
unstructured problems like computer
vision here
just to be clear tabular data means data
that's structured in a table like format
let's say in a database or in a data
frame that's why you face most business
out there
so before we get to the technical
details just a brief introduction i'm
from brazil and i'm based in dublin i'm
a staff data scientist at a mobile
gaming company i recently changed titles
to data science manager but since this
is a technical audience i want to give
more credibility
i have five years of experience of
applied machine learning i have worked
with anti-fraud credit risk lifetime
value and currently market attribution
and i have applied machine learning to
most of those problems i have used
mostly light gbm and xgboos on those
problems and they have served me quite
well over time
now i also have a master's degree in
deep learning specifically on
variational encoders and they have never
not served me well over time i have
never actually used deep learning to
solve a real problem that brings like
money to the business i have only spent
business money on gpus and cloud costs
so we have a packed agenda today it's
quite technical we can look at the
slides later i want to start with some
example uh that's going to motivate you
to use light gbm then i'm going to go
over how gradient booster trees work
what are some of the important
parameters you can tune how it handles
missing values and categorical features
the loss function menu including how you
can create your own custom loss
some other cool features like early
stopping and simple weights and finally
modern interpretability
so let's start with kaggle house price
prediction problem
anyone here was in the tutorial
yesterday for data validation
yeah a few people i was quite surprised
by the way it was a great tutorial i
recommend checking out later i was quite
surprised because uh the guy used the
same data set as i did complete
coincidence but maybe you're not just
very creative people here and the data
set which
quite small but interesting it is
interesting because we have 80 different
features and there are of different
types we have categorical numerical and
boolean features
we just have 3000 samples so this is a
very small data set and we evaluate this
on the
rmse the root mean squared error of the
log price it's not really real life but
cargo is never real life anyway
and here we start with a simple light
gbm baseline don't really focus on the
code here you can look at the notebook
later my point is that in just 18 lines
of code you can read a data set train a
model score and have a prediction ready
but okay how does it perform it can just
be a terrible model right
it's actually average
so not great not terrible we get to the
top 30 of the submissions here on the
right you have a histogram of the scores
of this competition and the hover is on
the our bin our performance so we are
exactly at the mode of the the
distribution here this means most people
had a similar solution
and for real life we know that this
might be more than enough
sometimes most of the times i would say
there is no point getting the extra
performance points because
who cares about log rmse score in real
life anyway you know it's just an
artificial metric but of course you can
also see that on the right side you have
a lot of very bad submissions so this is
what you want to avoid having a very
terrible model
not having the best model ever
we all know that to get a top score you
have to work heavily on feature
engineering and tuning and also doing a
lot of data pre-processing
so before you leave the talk because
you're not too impressed with the
results i just want to give like a broad
overview of how they perform overall
people who are used to kaggle they know
that light bmx work wonders for tablet
data problems so here is um
a chart that was publicized by friends
to actually the creator of keras this
was a few years ago so it must have
changed already and of course cara is
the top model here he just looked at the
top five teams on kaggle and we can see
here that carries the best but if you
some light bm and xgboos they are
more prevalent in cameras and the
reasons that actually this is just split
into two types of competitions for the
unstructured problems that computer
vision carers by torch dominate for the
tablet data sets exe boost and igbm
dominate
so my point here is that not only you
can get a reasonable baseline with just
a few lines of code but you can also get
to the top if you invest the time and
effort
so as i mentioned the data set is quite
complex even though it's small
here i'm showing the view from pendants
profiling
if you have never used pindest profiling
i highly recommend as a way to do
exploratory data analysis it provides
not just this summary view but also a
lot of deep dives on the notebook you
can check out the actual like full html
page and here we just see the summary
view and we can already see some things
which are interesting
the features are split into numeric and
categorical and we do have some missing
data here missing data is always a big
problem for most models out there
if you look at the alerts tab i'm not
going to show it here but it's going to
complain a lot about data problems it's
going to say some features are heavily
skilled to the right it's going to say
some features i have a lot of zeros some
have missing data some are highly
correlated some of the categories have
high cardinality so
where are the standard scalars my
solution what about the missing value
putation what about the categorical
encoding what about the parameter tuning
or the feature selection
i didn't do any of those stuff that
you'd regularly do you know for our
linear regression svm neural network and
we just ignore all of that even the
missing values and the solution just
worked
so how does light gpm handle off that
under the hood
before we get to like the cooler
features let's start with the basics
let's see how gradient boost trees works
in general
and let's start with just one single
regression tree here
and just to be clear it's always a
regression tree even if it's a
classification problem it's always
regression for classification i explain
a little bit later on the q a
and the idea is simple and we're going
to grow the tree leaf wise and the
difference from a regular decision tree
find one second learn is that it's going
to use a loss function based on the
gradients
of your error so it's not just going to
use some kind of impurity measure or
like variance measure it's actually
going to use the gradient to make the
best possible splits for each node
i have an exp explanation here
so the idea is that it's going to always
choose the leaf if the max delta allows
to grow and this is based on the
gradient
so the question is for every node which
threshold best splits the sum of
gradients between each child
and this is very computational intensive
but like light gbm and xc boost they
provide a fast approximation using
histograms of gradients the idea is
quite simple actually you just want to
map
the samples to histograms so instead of
handling let's say one million examples
you just handle uh 250 256 bins in a
histogram so now your problem to find
the best split is much
simpler and faster and you lose very
little performance
now
that we have a single regression tree
let's assemble them
if you had a random forest you just
train them in parallel with boosting the
idea is quite simple you build them in
an iterative fashion so
each new tree that's added to the symbol
is used to predict on the mistakes of
the previous trees so they learn the
residual the residual so every single
iteration you are getting lower and
lower lower residual because the trees
are just learning the residual
but something important to keep in mind
that we have a learning rate here to
prevent overfeeding
so each three contributions not just
the residual directly but it's the
residual times the learning rate this
makes that note is gonna dominate uh
your prediction in a way that you don't
learn the noise of the residuals
this clearly indicates that the learning
rate is a very important parameter to
tune
and the final prediction of the symbol
is gonna be first the initial prediction
which can be just the average of the
target
plus the contribution of each tree
times the learning rate if you just
summon sum them up that's how you get a
prediction from
gradient booster trees and symbol
so what are the most important
parameters you can tune to get a good or
reasonable performance out of the
lgbm
first the most important ones the number
of estimators or the number of trees
i recommend to use
a value maybe between 100 or 1000 but i
have used in the past even up to 5 000
trees you got to have a good
justification for that because that's
just computationally expensive
and the second most important one is the
learning rate
where i suggest using lower values in
the standard
and my suggestion here would be the
following since those parameters are
very intertwined that is the more trees
that you have the lower the learning
rate should be to prevent overfitting
you should train them together so
what you can do is first set the
learning rate to be small
and then find the optimal number of
trees with early stopping i'm going to
cover early stop in a few slides
and the remaining parameters that we
have like max depth of each tree or the
maximum number of leaves of each tree or
the bag infraction the feature fraction
all of them are going to prevent over
feeding on individual trees so it's kind
of hard to like know uh beforehand what
is the ideal value if you want to
optimize them you can use no random
search based optimization
but you know for most cases you can just
use the default values
and finally you have the objective
function this is super important because
this problem dependent this is going to
guide you
your model because this is going to
define directly the gradient of the loss
that's going to be used to build build
each one and everything of the splits so
i'm going to talk more about them later
all right let's go to the start covering
the cool features that happened behind
the scenes when i trained that model
the first one is missing value
imputation
so whenever i interview data science
candidates i always ask this question
how they would handle missing values in
their data sets
and most of the answers are something
like for numerical features we use the
mean or median imputation perhaps mode
for account data mediums better for
outliers for categorical features you
can just use an unknown class
some people suggest to build a model
that's going to predict the missing
values which my opinion is not a good
idea in general but i almost never hear
that some models handle them natively
and that's the case for light gbm and
xbox the idea is quite simple here
we just learned the missing value splits
on each node
so say that we have a node that splits
on square meters feature and we
by using that logic as explained before
we know that below 100 should go to the
left above 100 to go to the right
during training what happens is that if
there are missing values
on this feature it is simply going to
learn a separate split which minimizes
the loss but now only for the messy
value situations
this way not only you can tackle missing
values you can also optimize for them
you know what to do best when you face
them in real life
but sometimes that can lead to disaster
this is a real example that happened to
me i was working for
fintech i was building a credit risk
model i had great metrics was already in
production
and
a business analyst came to me and said
look your model gave me a perfect credit
score and i'm pretty sure that's wrong
because i'm a terrible credit card
player at first i was like oh the guy
must be joking he works for a bank but
no he did have a bad credit rating score
and i dig a little bit deeper and they
realized that the model was indeed very
wrong
um because a large set of important
features were missing in production for
a small set of users that included this
guy of course
but those features were never ever
missing in training so the model never
really learned what to do with them and
it has a default behavior and this
default behavior would just lead to like
low risk scores all the time it's
definitely not what you want those cases
so the lesson here is quite simple you
should never accept missing values in
production if there are none in training
no matter what method you use
so let's do the same for categorical
encoding we're going to interview about
this question so i'm giving away some
industry secrets here i get answers like
you can use label encoding to turn the
categories into numbers
this adds some arbitrary logic to the
to the scale it's weird but that works
well for trees in general
or you can use one hot encoding where
categories become a set of binary
features and this is not really great
for trees if you have a large
cardinality because then you have very
sparse features uh trees do not dwell
off them
or you can even get fancy and say that
you're going to use target encoding
where you use the average target value
by category which is powerful but risky
and you can use also frequency encoding
where you use the category frequency to
make a mapping of categories to numbers
now
light bm doesn't need all that remember
we had 40 categorical features on the
data set it didn't use any kind of
encoding
the way that lgbm handles categorical
features it's very similar to numerical
features it's just going to map them to
histograms so it's going to use the same
idea where
each feature is going to be mapped to a
histogram and this build using the
lowest gradients and then we start the
histogram according to the objective and
we find the best split
so this is very
reminiscent of target encoding because
we are using the actual objective of
your problem here to create the best
splits uh and this explains why it's so
powerful and useful in practice and
there is some regularization involved to
make sure that you don't over fetch
but if you have a problem where it's
mostly categorical data i would highly
recommend checking out catboost which
like a distant cause into a light bm exe
boost but it's focused mostly on
categorical features it just doubled
downs on the idea of using target
encoding for categories
okay let's go over the loss function
menu as i explained before we have to
define an objective and that's super
important because it's going to guide
what your mod is doing
and light beam offers a lot of options
you should not stick to the standard
stuff
uh if you have a regression problem the
standard is going to be the good old
mean squared error the l2 regularization
uh not regularization also objective
this is the default and it's going to
recover the mean value of the
distribution
or if you have outliers perhaps you can
use the mean absolute error and this is
going to recover the median value of the
distribution if you have a time series
problem you can use the mean absolute
percentage error if you have a problem
where intervals matter more than point
estimates you can use use the quantile
loss this is actually
super cool and underutilized because a
lot of people in practice they might use
some kind of
statistical modeling like a normal
distribution to get like a prediction
intervals and where you calculate the
variance here you can just say i want a
95 percent prediction interval and like
to be like gbm is going to provide you
one
final you have some more specialized
distributions for some particular kind
of problems
like 280 game and poisson
so if you have a classification problem
has different loss functions of course
for binary and multi-class and you even
have an option for ranking you just
don't have an option for survival
analysis but xc boost those offer that
possibility
so i want to go over like a real life
example where a different loss function
makes a lot of sense
this is the lifetime value model problem
on the chart here is
a symbol from a google paper
and we for many problems of lifetime
value have this kind of distribution you
have something which is bimodal and
right skilled so most users don't spend
a cent so they are all in that delta
function at zero and some users spend a
lot of money so they are here on this
right skill distribution note that the
x-axis is on the log scale
so how do you handle that
my first approach was to use a two-stage
model
one classifier that predicts paying user
notch so the probability of a pay user
and the regressor that predicts
conditional and pain what is the
expected value
and then to get the final output just
multiply multiply the probability of a
user times the conditional value on
being payers
and that worked was all right
then uh i attempted a zero inflated log
normal neural network quite a mouthful
uh this comes directly from this paper
here so i just use the implementation
even though the name is complicated the
idea is simple you just model explicitly
the statistical distribution that models
this behavior of bimodal and skewness
using a log normal a zero physical like
normal this also worked but i had to do
a lot of tune you know as always with
neural networks i had to like
standardize all the numeric scales i had
to take log transform of them i had to
create embeddings for the categorical
features i had to discover know the best
number of layers the number of neurons
per layer the learning rate and so on
and just performed similarly to the
two-stage model above
but the best solution was actually
a light gpm with just the 3d loss and
the 3d loss just works wonders of this
kind of bimodal problems and just with
one single model that can run like one
minute i build all of this complexity
now
you can also create your own custom loss
if the loss manual that you have
is not enough for you
i wouldn't recommend going down this
path unless you really need
that because
it starts to get a little bit hairy
because you're going to have to provide
the gradient and the hessian of the loss
function
explicitly now this is definitely less
fun than using let's say tensorflow or
pi torch because there's no automatic
differentiation for you so you gotta do
it by hand sometimes that's easy
sometimes that's very hard
but i have actually used that in the
past and i use exactly this example here
which is
we have an asymmetry in the error
function we wanna penalize more over
predictions compared to under
predictions this was just a business
constraint and our models are just over
predict overpredicting too much so i use
this asymmetric custom loss that comes
from this blog post
which just
those two functions here so not that
complex actually and it worked
so there are some times where this might
make sense because you can use all the
niceties all the goodies from igbm and
xboos
as i mentioned missing validation the
gradient
boosting trees of course the categorical
encoding plus you can
guide the model to do whatever you want
as long as you can provide degrading the
hessian
so i mentioned that you could do early
stopping to determine the optimal number
of iterations or the optimal number of
trees this idea here is quite simple
it's just like neural networks you just
have a validation stats and you're gonna
be adding more and more trees until
there's no improvement on the validation
stats and then you stop i applied this
to the kagga housing problem and it
gathered me a very tiny score
improvement which probably sound very
meaningful in real life but anyway
if you have a lot more data this can
make sense because if you have a lot of
data having more trees can really get
you to the next level
and oh yeah this is not really very
specific to like gbm rxc boost pretty
much every single machinery model there
have this kind of feature which is
simple weights or class weights i'm just
putting this here because i find this to
be heavily underutilized in practice and
instead of using over simply or under
sampling if you have an imbalance
problem just use balance class weights
that's much simpler much faster it's
going to lead to similar results
you can also use simple weights if you
have a problem where the samples are
weight differently for example let's say
you are building a churn model and you
have users of high value low value you
definitely want to prevent churn for
users with high value so just train your
model and add some extra weight for
those users high value and it's going to
learn how to handle them better than the
average user
same for credit risk you want to limit
your losses to the people who very high
limits so if you have a very high limit
just add a higher weight here
um anyone here has
heard or used smoke it's a method of
like oversampling oh just
just a few well
don't use mode
uh it's not just my opinion those guys
one is uh kaggle grin master the other
is the second learn creator
and we all three agree that mode is not
very useful in practice i won't have
time to go into details why not
and we have other cool features that i
haven't even talked about now
first you can add monotone history
constraints you can force the
relationship of a feature and the
prediction to be monotonic so whenever a
feature increases in value the
predictions must also increase in value
this is quite niche but might be useful
to have a more interpretable model or if
you have business constraints that force
whenever a value increases you expect
the prediction to increase as well or to
decrease
you can actually use a random forest
boosting method so if you need extra
let's say robustness or resilience you
can just use a good old random forest
that is you're just going to build the
trees in parallel not in the iterative
fashion but you gain all the advantages
that i cover here besides the gradient
boosting part so we're gonna be able to
handle missing values categories and so
on
you can also use distributed
computational and gpu support i've never
tried that myself for light bm but have
used that for xc boost and that just
worked wonders for large data sets i
just used xboos for spark and that was
so much better than use the spark
machine learning library
and finally for interpretability i would
suggest not to use the built-in feature
don't use split counter gain use chap if
possible shap is an awesome library it's
quite efficient and chap
provides interpretability on the simple
level so you can get the explanation of
the model is doing for each particular
sample here on the left i have two
examples and shapes just saying why the
model made one prediction in one
particular way and the other on a
different way so one is below average
the other is above average and have
different features contributing to this
and on the right you have kind of the
same view but now apply to multiple
samples so this is the test set of the
of that problem so here we see what the
model is doing in the test hatch and you
can find stuff that's obvious but nice
to know for example the top feature the
most important one which is the overall
quality
the higher the value of this feature
the
higher the prediction makes sense right
like the higher the quality of the house
the higher the price uh so this is
intuitive but just taking this look and
help you uncover a lot of problems
for example uh the business analysis
case where i found out about the missing
value problem was discovered just using
shap i just applied chap to that subset
of users which had weird credit ratings
and the insta just stood out in one
second
all features that shouldn't be missing
were missing and they were all pointing
out towards low risk so after i saw that
i realized those features were the
problem
and i'm getting to the conclusion here
so i hope that i showed you and convince
you that uh lgbm and xboos they provide
not only a reasonable baseline but they
also can get you to the next level if
you need or want
most of your tablet modeling needs are
already covered with the built-in
features so you don't have to worry
about standard scaling categorical
encoding missing validation just do a
good old fit project and that's it
that's going to work most of the times
i showed an example where it didn't work
so you are always going to be mindful
what is happening behind the scenes
that's the point of my talk here
and you can also use libraries that are
well integrated for example you can use
second learn not for the modeling part
because it just sucks
but you can use it for like train test
split for example you can use painless
profiling for eda you can use shab for
interpretability by just using that a
small amount of libraries you can
do most of what you need to do for
tableau problems without having to worry
too much about like choosing the best
model or tuning on your network
and by doing so this leaves you time to
focus on what really matters in applied
machine learning
which first building new features uh
this goes really in line with what uh
madison said about focusing on the data
not focusing on the model you should use
this to focus on features and the data
by for example gathering new data
sources or doing feature engineering
you can focus on proper evaluation
methodology because a random trained
test split is never really enough to
capture let's say the what the model is
going to face in real life so try to
create evaluation methodology that
really resembles what the model is going
to face for example maybe do a time
series approach because life is always
like a temporary nature
you can spend user time to translate the
model results into the business bottom
line so you can justify your high
paychecks
you can use
um this time to do the proper decision
making with the model output so do the
less mile no data science not just about
creating a jupiter notebook or just
showing some metrics it's about getting
your mortgage production and making
decisions based on the model outputs and
that's always much much harder than
training the model initially
and finally you can use it at the time
for model deployment infrastructure and
monitoring
you can never leave a model unattended
let's say no matter which model you
choose because well the data your
problem is always going to change over
time and making mistakes is so much more
costly than what you're getting by no
0.01 log rmse score
and i leave you partnering words of
wisdom from akaigo grindmaster
takes a lot of study to learn all the
necessary much learning tools
but it takes a lot of experience to
learn which ones to ignore thank you
thank you we've got ample time for
questions now
hi
excellent presentation thank you uh do
you have any experience with the
boosting parameter and especially the
difference between dart and gradient
boosting
to be honest i've never tried the dart
boosting i only tried the regular one
and the random forest one and uh
i never really looked into it
same here i really want to find somebody
that uses
so maybe not so useful
yeah
okay
any more questions
seems like everything was very clear
um aren't chap values quite
computationally expensive to calculate
um great question
uh what is really impressive about chap
is that the author of chap went to the
libraries of xcboost and hbm and he
implemented himself all the c plus plus
code to make that efficient
so he did all the heavy uh labor to make
sure that ship was going to be efficient
for light gbm and xc boost so it's going
to be a lot more efficient than you
apply on a random model which i agree
it's going to be terribly inefficient
but even so it's not yeah sometimes you
just gotta buy the bullet and do some
kind of sub sampling uh yeah even if
this efficiency i mentioned if you have
a very large data set it's going to be
too slow so my suggestion is just do a
sub sampling or just focus on the
subgroups that you are worried about
like i mentioned you can just focus on
the for that example on the high risk
scores that made no sense so by doing
that you're just gonna focus on what
matters
hi uh thank you very much for the
presentation i have a question about
shop i never use it but
do you know how it behaves when you have
high correlation between features
so let's assume that the first five
are highly correlated between each other
i don't think shep would have a problem
with this and chap also offers uh very
particular plots that just show the
relation of two features so if you want
to investigate this in particular you
can just use the sharp view which is not
presented here but it just shows the
correlation of the features and how that
relates to the output and so we can look
into that in very specific terms with
chap
but for this chart here as far as i
understand i could double check it
there is no problem having correlated
features
they're just going to be let's say
spread out because this is more actually
a pro question for the
boosie method itself
but since we are going to use
trees that are built with some feature
fraction you never want to build a model
where each tree learns all the features
at the same time uh each tree is not
gonna be completely dependent on one
feature or the other so if you take the
aggregate view of all the trees some are
gonna be using one of the feature and
another other trees are gonna be using
the other feature if they're correlated
and what happens that the contribution
of those features is going to be kind of
spread equally if you have like let's
say 100 correlated features the
importance of them should be roughly the
same and that's what you should see here
of chap those features should be like
let's say on the same level because they
should be have the same meaning here
so but see for instance we imagine that
one of this feature is actually very
important for us and one is
correlated to that through
another unobserved feature
so it's a spurious coloration and we
give
a lot of importance to a feature that
actually doesn't really matter for us is
it kind of a
problem in that sense maybe yeah that's
that's not a problem
so first let's imagine the situation
where the features are correlated and
it's not spurious then that's not a
problem whatsoever so it's not like a
linear model where i don't know having
correlated features can really know uh
throw a range into like the model
building
for trees they don't really care about
correlation between features they just
they're just gonna use them equally
roughly but yeah if the correlation is
spurious then it's a big problem because
they're probably gonna predict something
wrong in the test time
that would happen for pretty much any
kind of model family
so you gotta just to take some other
actions to prevent that from happening
for example an idea that i really like
is that you can have an extra model that
predicts train and test such
belonging so it's a model then certified
of predicting the targets it's a binary
classifier that predicts whether a
sample comes from the training search or
from the test search what is the point
is that if you have a spherical
correlation maybe this feature is going
to be
only used in the training set not the
test and that should raise a red flag
and should look into that
but that's just one way there are
multiple ways to do it yeah thank you
very much
anyone else
um thanks for talk that was really
insightful um so you mentioned cat boost
briefly earlier do you only recommend
using that when the majority of the
features you're modeling
are categorical or to put it another way
is it is there a detriment to use in cap
boost compared to light gbm when you're
only modeling maybe three or four
categorical features i don't have a lot
of experience with cat boost that's a
good question
from my understanding of not just my
experience but of the market they'll say
cat boost is mostly useful in that
situation so there's no point using a
model which perhaps less feature
complete in light gbm
if you don't have a lot of categorical
features and to be very honest my only
experience with cat boost was negative i
was trying to like improve on a simple
linear baseline and was only categorical
features
and i thought cat boos be so much better
than this linear model was like a
hackathon kind of project and in the end
it wasn't really so performed the same
as the linear model was the same the
first time ever in my life where like
great and boosted trees couldn't
outperform like a baseline
so after like this happened to me uh
this is just uh no simple size of one i
never went back to cat boost again i
just stuck no to light gbm maxibles
sorry
good luck in the absolute sense
um
oh that's one million dollar question
though it was an actual real business
application making like uh millions of
decisions per day was like a real-time
beating of at auctions and we were
making a profit but you never know how
much more you can make so comparing to
other players in the industry yeah we
could definitely do better but i'm not
sure if the problem was the model itself
was
the data because we are just biased by
the data that we have right
sorry
is this related to this
okay
any situations we'd rather use xgb
rather than like gbm
yeah so when i started to use lgbm that
was maybe four years ago
light gbm had an edge it had more
features for example it had this nice
categorical encoding method that xbox
didn't have at the time and was just
faster and in practice perform equally
or better so was just no win-win
situation and uh after i changed to ibm
i never really looked back but for this
lecture in particular i looked back and
actually realized that xboos had
advanced a lot so they are more like
let's say
they have more parity in features so
they're kind of converged into the same
direction even second learns converges
to the same direction second learn has
now the histogram gradient booster trees
which just kind of copies the same
algorithm here that i explained uh it's
also much better than the regular random
forest or green booster trees i can
learn so everyone's converging to the
same place and light gpm was there like
xbox was the first uh but then light
beam provided a very solid
implementation and today i'll say that's
still very solid and i don't see any
reason to use xc boost unless you have
something very particular that xboos
does better for example survival
analysis loss function uh i have used
that in the past that was very cool next
boost lightbm doesn't have that so
that's one example
um did you use a modal agnostic version
of sharp or is it a sharp package
particular for tree-based models
and and also did you try lime and how
would you compare alignment shop
i have used lime many many years ago
and my experience with flying is that it
works well for more
unstructured problems like texts or
images
i work with flying for document
classification and made a lot of sense
uh but for tableau data problems i was
never really impressed with lime at
least that was four or five years ago so
i'm not sure if they have improved
with chap i always use uh the particular
principle method they provide not the
mod agnostic one because it's just so
much more efficient
okay
time for one more question if anyone has
got
thank you great q a
thank you very much
[Applause]